[Applause]
a promise finally fulfilled a year after
taking office the leftist government of
Gustavo Petra announced the creation of
Colombia's first ever Ministry to
address the country's deep economic and
social inequality
vice president Francia Marquez an
afro-columbian environmentalist will
lead it
today we're fulfilling our campaign
promise to create this new institution
an institution that will take care and
work tirelessly to guarantee the rights
of the most vulnerable people in our
country and to the most vulnerable
regions
the new ministry of equality and Equity
was inaugurated in La guajira one of
Colombia's most impoverished and
underdeveloped regions symbolizing the
task at hand
here families walk for hours daily in
search of drinkable water and child
mortality remains stubbornly High
[Applause]
Marcus will be responsible for bringing
government services to them and other
vulnerable marginalized populations it
will be financed by the government
recent tax reform with the starting
budget of 125 million dollars
[Applause]
this is not a big budget but it's a way
to start articulating different sectors
of government to create efficient
policies to combat social economic and
political inequalities it will be a very
long-term task but the important thing
right now is to start
Colombia's first authorized president
has endured racism and discrimination
for her entire life displaced by
violence she worked as a housemate to
raise her children and later earned a
law degree in the 2018 Goldman prize for
her work against illegal mining
the ministry has two objectives number
one is is to actually be a symbol of
change the other is to actually
accomplish something and the problem is
the first objective is easy to do the
second is much more difficult
for many underrepresented Colombians
Francia Marquez who has faced and
overcome the barriers of this very
unequal Society is the right person to
try to start transforming Colombia into
a country where people's future depend
on their talent and not their origin
Alessandra Al Jazeera Bogota